Let's start off by looking at two important
data relationships when you do modeling in data
store. They are ancestor relationships and has-a relationships.
Starting off with the ancestor relationship in data store
it is possible to specify that an entity
has an ancestor entity. There are two important
rules for ancestor relationships. First of all, it
needs to be assigned when the entity is created.
And secondly it can never be changed so
those are things to think about when you model
an ancestor relationship. And given those rules, please note
that the ancestor relationship is not the same as
the is-a relationship in object oriented modeling. In conference
central, we will use the ancestor relationship for the
conference kind that you will create shortly. Where the
ancestor will be the user who created the conference.
Technically speaking though since the users are identified
through their profile entities, so in this case the
conferences will have the key of the profile
entity as their ancestor key. The other relationship we
will be using is the has-a relationship. We
will be using this relationship to model conferences which
users are attending. To do this we will
add a property to the profile entity which specifies
the attended conferences. So each profile will have
a property that contains the conferences that they are
attending, observe that this relationship can easily change.
We can deregister from conferences and register to new
ones, so it is not bounded by the
strict rules of the ancestor relationship. So those are
the basics of these relationships and that's also
enough theory for now. Time to do some coding.